from iconic jedi to devious mutants to
legendary action heroes hollywood
history is awash with cancelled origin
stories but why were these projects
shelved and did we really need them in
the first place
today x-men origins wolverine is a
widely derided punchline one whose
largest legacy is inspiring the
radically different creative direction
the franchise took for the wolverine and
logan initially however there were plans
by 20th century fox to use this project
as a way to kick off a whole series of
x-men origins movies wolverine was the
first mutant to get a prequel adventure
but there were originally plans for
magneto to headline a feature in the
series 2. in april 2007 it was announced
david esquire was to helm a magneto
movie building off a script penned by
sheldon turner of course magneto wasn't
a surprising pick for those familiar
with the original trilogy of x-men
movies not only was he a prominent part
of those films but he also has a very
well-known origin story filled with more
than enough drama to hold up an entire
superhero flick the project even got far
enough to inspire original portrayer ian
mckellen to express interest in
returning to the role in some capacity
however growing interest in a potential
x-men first class movie led fox to
change directions taking many of the
ideas dreamed up for the magneto movie
and incorporating them into an ensemble
prequel film
peace was never an option
the negative critical reception to x-men
origins wolverine was simply the last
straw for fox's x-men origin series
the internet is largely aware of the
unmade hellboy 2 the golden army
follow-up hellboy 3 a passion project
for director guillermo del toro that
never found proper financing less
well-known is another extension of the
hellboy franchise that was once proposed
at the start of the 2010s rather than
pursuing hellboy 3 distributor universal
pictures wanted to kick off a whole
series of movies entitled from the files
of the bprd referring to the government
organization that employs hellboy and
his supernatural chums screenwriter
peter briggs explained on facebook that
this series would have kicked off with a
prequel film chronicling the earlier
exploits of the golden army villain
prince nuata this project would have
gone back in time and followed nuada
long before he fought hellboy as he
navigated various major real world
conflicts this movie was actually an
active development on two separate
occasions with universal showing great
interest in the project both times
however briggs revealed that it was
unceremoniously cancelled once the 2019
hellboy movie was announced leaving
prince nueta's prequel in the dust
when disney first bought lucasfilm the
company's bigwigs decided they wanted to
produce more than just a new trilogy of
star wars films they also plan to expand
the franchise into a series of spin-off
movies called star wars stories the
first of these rogue one dropped in 2016
and was a roaring success but the
anthology movie approach to star wars
was paused when the second installment
solo underwhelmed financially at one
point however this master plan was set
to include a solo movie for none other
than jedi master yoda in august 2017 the
hollywood reporter revealed that a movie
based on yoda was being contemplated by
lucasfilm brass no further details ever
emerged on this proposed yoda movie such
as a potential creative team or what the
story might have involved given that
yoda has lived for hundreds of years in
the star wars universe there are untold
amounts of stories that this potential
feature could have covered however the
ensuing decision to table future
anthology films made a yoda origin film
redundant as did the mandalorians focus
on the character of kroku
2007's fantastic four rise of the silver
surfer debuted the first ever big screen
version of the marvel comics icon known
as the silver surfer portrayed by doug
jones physically and lawrence fishburne
through voiceover his appearance in the
fantastic four sequel was just the
beginning of a long-lasting cinematic
career for the server 20th century fox
even sought to spin this incarnation of
the character off into his own solo
movie the studio had long been
interested in launching silver surfer as
a solo franchise with andrew kevin
walker working on a screenplay as far
back as july 2000 however it took rise
of the silver surfer to really get the
gears moving in february 2008 less than
a year after that film's release
screenwriter j michael strzinski
revealed at a wondercon panel that a new
silver server film would explore the
character's origins and feature the
debut of a comic's accurate version of
galactus over thanksgiving 2009
strazinski reached out to ign personally
to reveal that his version of the silver
surfer was on pause thanks to fantastic
four's disappointing box office
performance but he also noted that a new
take on the surfers story was in
development this incarnation of the
project never went forward either
however thanks partially to fox shifting
its focus to a full-on reboot of
fantastic four and we all know how that
went
say that again
it's fantastic
yes it is
after a good date die hard took the die
hard movies to a whole new low in terms
of critical reception it seemed like it
was time to drastically shake up the
franchise such a bold move emerged
through a project entitled mclean which
was meant to explore john mclean's life
as a cop in the 1970s the idea was to
introduce a younger version of mclean
though the film wouldn't entirely do
away with the previous installments
either producer lorenzo dibonaventura
told empire we are going to explore john
mclean in his 20s but just as prominent
is the 60 year old version with this
story structure firmly established
updates on the screenplay for mclean
emerged as late as 2019 but the disney
fox merger saw every title a 20th
century fox thrown into chaos including
mclean by july 2021 the news had come
down that the movie was no more bada
ventura has explicitly blamed the disney
fox deal for the production's demise
leaving this origin story as little more
than a fantasy of die hard's most
die-hard fans
the rambo franchise really does seem
impossible to kill thanks to 2008's
rambo and 2019's rambo last blood
sylvester stallone's iconic character
has stuck around even through the
changing movie landscape of the 21st
century hot on the heels of last blood
stallone revealed that he'd figured out
a way to keep the character going for
just a little longer via a prequel
chronicling the early years of john
rambo during an interview with screen
rant stallone mentioned that he hoped a
rambo prequel might eventually happen
and continued i always thought of rambo
when he was
16 or 17 that he was the best person you
could find he was the captain of the
team he was the most popular kid in
school super athlete he was like jim
thorpe and the war is what changed him
if you saw him before he was like the
perfect guy despite stallone's
enthusiasm for this project there have
been no further updates on a rambo
prequel part of that is likely due to
the global box office performance of
rambo last blood which came in below the
worldwide gross of its predecessor and
with this apparent lack of momentum it
could be that rambo's enduring big
screen presence has finally come to an
end
in that long period between superman 4
the quest for peace and superman returns
warner brothers went through countless
concepts for what a new superman film
could look like one of those proposed
projects was superman flyby which would
have once again tackled the famous
origin story of the kryptonian superhero
the production started under the
stewardship of brett ratner before
transitioning over to mcgee with both
filmmakers sharing a goal of relaunching
the character for a new era of superhero
movies for a moment this cursed
production seemed to be moving along too
until variety reported that it suddenly
wasn't the disruption occurred when mkg
stepped down from the project empire
reported creative disputes between mcgee
and warner brothers were to blame for
this development with these issues
culminating in a disagreement over where
to film the movie mcgee would later
clarify that it was specifically his
fear of flying that clashed with warner
brothers desire to film in australia
leading to him losing out on the gig
eventually brian singer would step in to
direct superman returns which went in a
radically different direction with the
story not only by skipping a retelling
of superman's origins but also in
creating a spiritual sequel to richard
donner's 1970s take on the character
in the wake of batman and robin's
critical and financial failure warner
brothers decided to take the batman
series in a brand new direction holy
hutzpah specifically the studio was
interested in a gritty new origin story
hiring darren aronofsky in 2000 to
direct a film adaptation of the frank
miller comic batman year one aiming for
an r rating and developing its own
storyline rather than slavishly devoting
itself to the comic batman year one was
shaping up to be a unique chronicling of
batman's first few months as a crime
fighter unfortunately by 2002
aronofsky's take on year one had been
passed over by warner brothers brass in
favor of a proposed batman and superman
movie another element that led to the
demise of year one was dispute
overcasting aronofsky wanted joaquin
phoenix to inhabit the lead role while
warner brothers chose freddie prince jr
for the part ironically while batman
year one fizzled out a gritty take on
batman's early days as a superhero would
eventually be told by christopher nolan
with 2005's batman begins not to mention
the batman the next adaptation of the
caped crusader which borrows heavily
from batman year one
channing tatum's name has been thrown
around for the role of gambit for well
over a decade but in the 2010s he
finally got serious about developing a
gambit movie in 2015 tatum told empire
that the first draft of the screenplay
had been completed and that it would
take a subversive approach to the
superhero origin story though things
sounded promising gambit took a
discouraging detour when director rupert
wyatt departed the project shortly
before filming was set to begin from
there the project was plagued by
multiple release date delays and saw
both doug lyman and gore verbinski
stepping into the director's chair only
to later leave by january 2019 tatum's
commitment to the project was taken to a
new level when deadline reported that
the actor was interested in directing
the troubled production himself
unfortunately tatum never got the chance
to even lobby gambit's origin story in
march 2019 disney closed its purchase of
the film's distributor 20th century fox
which handed the character back to
marvel studios two months later gambit
was officially dead bringing tatum's
relentless pursuit to an unhappy end
universal was so convinced that it's
2017 take on the mummy would
successfully springboard the so-called
dark universe franchise that the studio
greenlit a second installment ride of
frankenstein the movie was to be
directed by bill condon who previously
helmed a movie about original bride of
frankenstein filmmaker james whale
called gods and monsters this new take
on the origins of that famous monster
was rumored to star angelina jolie as
the titular creature with javier bardem
officially signed on to portray
frankenstein's monster while the project
assembled some buzzy lead actors this
new bride of frankenstein soon hit an
insurmountable roadblock the exceedingly
disappointing box office returns
delivered by the mummy immediately cast
a dark shadow over the whole dark
universe four months after the mummy
debuted the start date for bride of
frankenstein was delayed and the project
was sent straight back to development
hell two years later content revealed to
collider that universal's trepidation
over the budget and scope of bride of
frankenstein also contributed to its
cancellation
now condon's movie and the dark universe
as a whole appears to be very much dead
and buried
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you